si je te disais que je veux écrire
bon ça recommence berra s'est pas de
cette façon que tu vas trouver un mari
je ne me marierai pas ni maintenant ni
jamais bon c'est clair et net
workforce celle est douce et romantique
tu crois que ça de combien
rassure toi
ils n'ont que très peu d influence
tu dois écrire je t'assure personne ne
m'avait encore jamais dit ça
nous sommes liés mais trois
mousquetaires et moi
je viens d'apprendre que je suis admise
à oxford
on doit laisser une empreinte sur terre
et bien édouard montpetit frère s'il ya
du but subite
il n'a que 18 ans d'autres jeunes se
sont déjà engagés je regarde quoi si je
reste
tu t'es engagé toi aussi
combien de générations rend un privilège
de vivre un tel moment
je reviendrai
aulas
voilà
il cherche des volontaires je serai au
plus proche de lui c'est là que je dois
aller
notre génération ne s'en remettra jamais
on nous a volé notre jeunesse
ce que tu as là
il faut page mer c'est peut-être
attentats
la vie l'amour et toi
pensez à ce que ça représentait à mes
yeux
je ne vous oublierai jamais
je vous en fais la promesse
à vous tous
c'est décidé on n'a plus peur
on n'a plus peur